hi this is a special alt shift X live
stream to talk about the new trailer for
the second Denny vov Dune movie Dune
part two I'm here with a special guest
YouTube Quinn from Quinn's ideas thanks
for coming on Quinn no problem man
anytime how's it going guys it's great
to be back on this channel super excited
for the trailer super excited to talk to
you about it yeah we've got heaps to
cover lots of surprises in this trailer
uh this will be a bit of a spoilery live
stream we will talk about events that'll
happen in the upcoming movie uh so you
know all of that first book all of that
next movie we will mention some big
events from it but uh don't let that
worry you it's a bit like the preent uh
that Paul has in the June movie Frank
Herbert spoils half of June's story in
the first few chapters himself so uh
embrace the visions of the future be
like Paul and I and I feel like between
the three trailers if you're watching
them and engaging with content on them
like you probably know what's up anyway
cuz they do kind of show a lot the
trailers have shown a lot I feel like if
you could take all the little bits and
piece them together you might have a
good chunk of the movie's narrative yeah
yeah I was surprised by um how many
shots we got of the final battle for for
oracus with the sandworms attacking the
Sak car I thought that was done
beautifully yeah or even like the
nuclear uh weapons thing we got that in
the last trailer but I was surprised
that they even showed that because
that's also like a pretty big moment in
the book that you would expect them to
not maybe show in a trailer to like
reserve showing that for the moment but
I did hear that this movie the runtime
is like two hours and 46 minutes or
something like that so it's a lot longer
than the first movie it's Blade Runner
2049 length so um it's possible that
there's like so much in the movie that
this we think we're seeing like all the
exciting moments but maybe there's a lot
more that remain to be
seen yeah yeah they they it's
interesting that this second movie is
going to be so long because like the
first movie I feel like they cut out so
much from the first half of the first
June book um whereas this second movie
they're expanding it and adding all of
this stuff that wasn't in the book so
it's quite a different kind of
adaptation that they're doing with this
second
movie yeah I mean I was saying that I I
thought that um with the first movie it
did seem like they were kind of treading
lightly like they didn't want to like
make the movie too long they didn't want
to include too many weird things they
didn't want to include too much that
would I think scare away like the
average movie goer um and I think that
VN is a little bit Freer with this one
and I think he's putting more of his own
like ideas in it as well and you know uh
he has said that it's more of like a a
war movie which as you know the all the
action scenes in the Dune book are very
understated it's very like happening in
the background um but I imagine that the
movie will focus a lot more on those
types of sequences I imagine that be a
lot more in the moment when it comes to
these action scenes um because it yeah
like I said it happens in the background
in the book mostly yeah I mean part of
the fun for me of the June book is that
everything is so sort of yeah subtle and
indirect and and internal focusing on
thoughts and conversations right up
until the climactic ending where all of
this violence and action explodes out of
nowhere and it's shocking when when that
happen all at once um it sounds like the
second June movie is not going to have
that um so much because it looks like
there were many many action set pieces
uh rather than just the big climactic
one at the
end yeah I mean yeah looks like they're
going to be really getting into you know
maybe what stear was doing with the
Smugglers and you know they're going to
be getting into like several clashes
between the har conin and um the fan so
we're going to it's a it's I feel like
the movie is about the war between the
fan and the Haron at its heart that's
what this film is I think yeah they're
certainly focusing on um a lot of other
different Side Stories within the War uh
let us know in the live chat if there
are any audio issues apparently Quinn is
louder so I'll adjust that um yeah well
we did see more of like gurnie with the
Smugglers and we've seen a bunch of
shots throughout the trailers of uh you
know Paul and Chie with their missile
launcher rocket weapon attacking this
spice Harvester which you know the sort
of the twist of that in the book is that
uh this is gurny and the Smugglers who
are being attacked by Paul and chy and
the freman and they only realize Paul
only realizes after slaughtering half of
gurn's men that oh this isn't my enemy
this isn't the hinin this is my good
friend gie hick and I've just killed a
bunch of his dudes and so I I hope they
sort of capture the surprise and the
weirdness of that conflict
movie I love the fact that gurny hick
was you know making his way on oracus
you know getting in good with the
Smugglers and you know being a Survivor
he wasn't going to let oracus destroy
him so I I really like that aspect and
I'm glad that is something that is being
shown in this film as well I really like
gnie H as a
character yeah yeah and and it's all
about that getting in tune with the
environment type stuff I I thought the
design of his um still suit or I suppose
this is like a spice mining outfit that
he's wearing here um I thought it was
kind of interesting because this outfit
looks reminiscent of some of the sakar
outfits we saw uh with the big sort of
glass Dome helmet design yeah um so it's
interesting seeing him in that get up
like it shows that he's not freman you
know cuz the Smugglers exist in this
sort of in between worlds where they
where they are not as attuned to the
environment as the Fran are they're sort
of these Interlopers
between um like you know the Imperials
and the honens and the fans they're in
this really interesting
position yeah uh
definitely um
yeah one of the adjacent groups yeah it
it's interesting uh you know we've got
all these shots of there's this big like
nuclear explosion happening in front of
Paul uh but there's also these shots of
ornithopter firing on the shield wall to
like break the shield wall
mountains and and it's interesting that
these are like two separate events cuz
to my
understanding Paul uses the family
nuclear weapons to blow up the shield
wall break the shield wall yeah but we
also see this additional attack with the
orops attacking the shield wall as
though it's like two separate attacks
I'm kind of puzzled by that cuz I
thought that was all just one Atomic
strike that Paul
does yeah in the book it definitely is
I'm not sure maybe this was some other
incident or maybe they were using these
bombs for a different purpose I guess it
remains to be seen because I can't pick
out any specific Moment In the book that
this could potentially be yeah it's I do
know I do know that there are going to
probably be some significant changes for
the book what one one thing that I'm
pretty sure is not going to happen is
I'm pretty sure they're not going to
give because you said we were going to
talk about spoilers yeah I'm pretty sure
they're not going to give Paul and chny
that first lato I'm pretty sure we're
not going to see the baby that is killed
in the raid right so um I'd be shocked
if that was in the movie um so I don't
know I don't know yeah yeah so for those
who haven't read the book um at one
point there is a Time Skip and we find
that Paul and Chie have had a baby that
they named leato uh but this baby lato
is killed in a harken and raid and it's
it's kind of a weird little subplot that
happens because you know we don't get to
see this baby and not much it's just
something that sort of happens off
screen it's born and then it dies and
it's kind of a motivation for Paul to go
against the Hance I guess but it's not
like he needed additional motivation so
it's this really weird little subplot
that happens and it also makes the it
also makes the naming scheme confusing
because there is a second lato the
second when Paul and Chie have another
baby also called lato so ler the second
is actually kind of really ler the third
it's just a very confusing additional
plot that I the initial the I can see
them cutting it out yeah yeah I was
going to say yeah the initial child
almost feels like an afterthought in the
original Dune book it's like oh and then
they they also had a that got killed and
then yeah it makes it even weirder that
he does name the other kid lato weird
and confusing almost like he was like oh
I lost that one I guess I'll replace it
with another one
yeah and you know I I guess what they
are increasing the focus on is chy and
B's relationship um they're definitely
focusing this around their intimacy and
their love which is something that we
don't see a lot of in the first June
book um the the sort of tragedy and the
payoff for Paul and ch's love comes more
in the second book spoilers when you
know Charlie chy dies in child birth and
then Paul walks into the desert um
and and so it's kind of weird that
they're focusing so much on Paul and
Chin's love in the first book they're
changing it because they're adding this
conflict it seems where Chie is in
opposition to Paul's role as a prophet
we see Chie say this prophecy is how
they enslave us and I love this shot CU
we can see all the fman like heads bowed
in prayer and she's like standing and
and and yelling at her people saying you
know stop praying and open your eyes to
the truth that we are being
manipulated which is which is a really
big change Johnnie doesn't do this in
the book yeah it's certainly a departure
and it is a change that I definitely
like because like you said they're doing
a lot I think in this movie to develop
um Paul and ch's relationship and to add
more you know Dynamics to it um which I
really like um so um yeah I think I
think this is something that's needed
for this movie you need someone to be at
the opposition to Paul right because
these freemen um including sgar I think
are really invested in this idea of this
Lisa alib this voice from the outer
world this person that's going to come
in and free them from oppression of
so they're really invested in this idea
so although like chny is definitely
completely right the prophecy definitely
enslaves them the JZ sewed those myths
to manipulate the fan I think that what
she's saying is mostly going to fall on
deaths on deaf ears because it's you're
dealing with fanaticism there's a line
that comes from one of the other
trailers from stear where he basically
says it's not clear who he's talking to
but he's saying I don't care what you
believe this is what I believe because
it's not just
it's not just the fact that he beli he
wants to believe he needs to believe
because he they see it as the only path
forward the only path to their freedom
and at this point they're so close so I
can't imagine that Paul is actually
going to that Chie I mean is actually
going to cause any change in the minds
of the fen that she's like kind of
prosti here too yeah I agree because in
the book it's very abstract and subtle
this idea that oh yeah there's a
prophecy of the Savior but it's really
dangerous and it's actually not in the
firman's interests and we we learn about
these ideas mostly through Paul's
thoughts and that's really difficult to
show in a movie so I think it does make
sense to change China's character to
make her the character who is who is
trying to prevent the freman from being
swept up in this um cult of personality
around Paul and this and this Jihad that
is coming and I think that the sense of
her like struggling and failing to save
the fman from being swept up in Paul's
Messianic leadership I think that'll
give us a really like strong emotional
sense of the theme you know it connects
this abstract theme to an actual
character's motivations in a way that I
think makes sense so yeah it's it's
quite a bold change from the book but I
I think it is needed to make people
really understand what this story is
about and this story is about the danger
of political and religious uh leaders
having too much power and too much
influence yeah someone asks how can chny
be a skeptic and yet stand by Paul
through do Messiah and my answer to that
is because she they love each other
she's in love with Paul at trates and
that actually does mean a lot for human
beings when you're like in love with
somebody so even though she doesn't
agree with what he's doing necessarily
she still loves him and she's willing to
stand by him at least I think it would
be the deal because like like we said
it's different in the book I mean that
that I think is what could make it
interesting right like there's so much
more drama there if Chie loves Paul as a
person but hates his cult of personality
and his Messianic leadership that's a
really interesting tension for Chie like
in the book Chie mostly sort of just
blindly has faith in Paul as well as
loving Paul she doesn't really question
his uh his leadership and vision having
having attention in the movie canon is
potentially interesting I I thought it
was really interesting in this trailer
when Paul says to Chie my allegiance is
is to you do you believe me and and and
I think sort of part of the implication
here is that Paul is loyal to charie but
he's not necessarily loyal to the best
interests of the freman because Chie
talks in this trailer about you know the
the freman act for the good of the
freman for the mutual benefit of the
freman whereas Paul I think part of the
reason she says that is because Paul is
not acting in the best interests of the
freman he's saying to Chie I love you
specifically but he's making no promises
about the best interests of the freman
collective yeah one of my favorite lines
oh sorry go on I was just going to say
one of my favorite lines in the entire
Dune Saga and it comes from Children of
Dune paraphrasing it's when Paul is
having a conversation with his son leato
II in the desert and leato says to Paul
it's a shame you were never really fan
father or something like that um and
it's just like such a stab at Paul at
trades because he he was never really
fan he was utilizing the fan he was
harnessing desert power but he was not
fan in the same way that his children
were fan being you know the children of
fan the children of a fan woman and then
also having those fan ancestral memories
they were really fit in a way that Paul
never actually was so I I always thought
that was really interesting yeah that
that's I I I think a great point is that
Paul you know this this story is about
Paul becoming fan quote unquote and like
learning the way of the desert and
becoming a part of this people as is
fitting for a hero's journey you know so
many so many stories about heroes are
about a hero joining an another world a
Fantastical world and and becoming the
ruler of it but part of the subversion
of that fantasy Trope is that Paul isn't
really a true fman acting in True fman
Values I mean I guess he is in the sense
that he walks into the desert in the end
I mean that is about him affirming fan
values but but nonetheless in many ways
Paul isn't a real fan he's laughing he's
taking on the appearance of a freman in
order to use the fan and so that's I
agree it's so great when he's told that
he was never quite a true fan you know
he was just Lawrence of Arabia he was
just a European wearing this local
desert people appearances without
necessarily having the heart of it yeah
absolutely Paul is such a complex and
interesting character and I'm really
excited that it's basically official
that VNV is pushing for the Dune Messiah
movie he almost done with the script and
he really wants to get to at least the
ending of dun Messiah to kind of give an
ending to the Paul of Trad Saga CU I
think v no sees Messiah as the end of
Paul the Tres and he would be right in a
way because you could argue that like
when he walks into the desert it's the
death of paulat trates and the beginning
of you know the prophet so yeah just I'm
very curious to see if we can get the
Dune Messiah movie and to see like how
that unfolds on screen in v no
fashion yeah yeah I mean we've talked
before about how June Messiah is such a
strange book um I'm very curious to see
if it gets made into a movie what it
would be like I I also found it
interesting in the trailer this this
stuff where Chie says that you know you
Paul you come from this aristocratic
world of dukes and great houses and you
know blood you know lineage is how you
get power whereas we the freman we are
equal and we work for the benefit of all
and I thought that was interesting
because you know it's definitely true
that in the book The freman have a focus
on acting for the interests of the group
of the tribe sometimes you got to
sacrifice an individual for the sake of
uh the good of the tribe and the freman
collective um and the book connects that
to some Islamic Concepts as well of
istis I'm I'm no Islamic scholar but
there are certain Islamic terms that are
used by Frank Herbert in the book um to
connect the ideology of the freman to
ideas of general interest and in in
ideas of law law and common good um but
it's also interesting like this idea of
fan all being equal
because in some senses the fman are a
meritocracy there's the idea that the
leader is the one who is strong who is
most able to provide for the group um
but when you look at who the leaders of
the freman are they kind of are an
aristocratic family not unlike the great
houses because the the great leaders of
the freman who we know of in the books
are there's like Paro kindes who taught
them about ecology and then there's
Poo's son leet K who is a woman uh in
the first un movie and then SAR who
becomes the leader of all the freman in
June book one uh he is the uncle of
charie or possibly the great uncle
depending on who you ask and then you
know Paul uh marries Chie and become
well doesn't marry Chie but Paul has a
relationship with Chie and he's the
leader so if you actually look at who
the leaders of the fman are they're all
related it's one big family group of fan
ruling all the femen so like it is quite
a lot like one of the aristocracies of
the great houses I think so the so I
think it's yeah go on I was just going
to say I I think it's really hard for
human beings to avoid nepotism you know
I feel like it's almost like a natural
thing you think this guy was a great
leader perhaps his son will be a great
leader and I think humans naturally
gravitate towards that kind of thinking
when picking leaders yeah and that's a
point that Frank makes in the books over
and over is that even even a good
political system is subject to
corruption and you know power uh
destroying you know values and integrity
and and so you know it is compatible
with with the books that you get issues
like that but um yeah I I think it's a
really I think it's interesting that
this line is in the trailer talking
about these you know values of the
freman about equality and the general
good and and I think that probably the
purpose for it is that part of this
story is about how Paul's influence and
Paul's leadership eventually corrupts
the values of the freman and It
ultimately damages and degrades freman
culture and so the Great Triumph of the
freman ultimately leads to the the
destruction of what made them who they
are so so I think that's probably why
they're talking about fman values here
to show their degradation
later yeah almost um certainly and what
it was interesting what you were saying
about the Freeman earlier um and their
values and how you know the tribe is
more important than the individual um
there is a specific quote that I that
I'm kind of blanking on now but
essentially it's talking about about how
you cut away the rot so that the hole is
stronger you know the fan only take in
what makes them stronger right so that's
why um in the begin in in Dune when they
encounter Paul and Jessica in the desert
they're going to kill Jessica at first
until she demonstrates her usefulness to
the fman she demonstrates that she knows
the weirding way and when they recognize
that there is that she has something to
offer then they're like okay we can we
can work with this but they're
utilitarian which is I think is a strong
is what makes them is part of what makes
them so strong yeah and that's a
philosophy that comes up throughout all
the books and from a bunch of different
organizations you know the Ben like like
this evolutionary idea that you have to
um that the strong has to Triumph to
pass on the not only the genetics but
like the ideological ideas um the
political structures like the strong
survived so that the species can survive
collectively and it's quite a brutal
hard philosophy I think like I think
we've talked before about how Dune is
very much a story about superhuman
individuals who have superhuman
abilities of pressence and combat and
and June is not a series that cares very
much about average people and just the
the you know the vast majority of people
in this universe are these peasants who
have no rights and no power and the
books are not very interested in them
this is story about superhumans
triumphing for the good of the species
or the survival of the species
supposedly so you know I I think it's
interesting to think about that
philosophy at the heart of this story
it's definitely about exceptional people
right and that goes back all the way to
like you know you know why there's no
machines not no no thinking machines in
the series because Frank Herbert was
very concerned or very interested in you
know how far can humans evolve
themselves eles and how like you know
basically awesome can we become like how
far mentally can we stretch ourselves
how far physically can we stretch
ourselves so he's really only concerned
with the people that have stretched
themselves the most you know like the
mints and the B Jr all these sick freaks
and Weirdos that have like really pushed
what it is to be human to like the very
very limits like he's I think Frank
Herbert was just kind of obsessed with
that idea because it's an idea that he
continues to play with in the later book
too so yeah I think that goes all the
way down to like what he the idea that
he had when he was first conceptualizing
the whole thing yeah a a celebration of
human
exceptionalism I guess you could call it
so some other cool stuff in the trailer
uh I I I enjoy how Paul says you know
the trailer is uh framed by these dreams
and nightmares that Paul is having these
visions of the future that he's having
so good and he's talking about how the
Visions it's only fragments and it's not
clear what is happening in these visions
and in a fun meta kind of way these
fragmentary unclear visions that Paul is
describing that's just like the trailer
the trailer itself is a bunch of
fragmentary visions of different shots
of this of the future of this movie
we're about to see so it's quite met
about um the trailer itself I really
appreciate it that they it's said in the
trailer that Paul is seeing a bunch of
all these possible Futures I'm glad that
was said cuz I feel like people have
argued with me before when I've said
that Paul is seeing a bunch of possible
Futures and you know picking one you
know and so I'm glad that they kind of
they're establishing that fact in this
movie that he sees multiple Futures and
he chooses the one to go down and I
really really loved when he when he was
talking about how he saw one Narrow Path
forward um and the thing about that
narrow path is that although most of the
other paths lead to you know the
destruction of house at trades and
victory for house AR Conan maybe most of
those other paths don't lead to the
devastating events that that are going
to take place later in the human
Universe the path for what's interesting
is the path for the survival of House of
tradies is not a path that benefits most
of humanity and Paul knows this and yet
he's choosing to go forward with this
path anyway because he's more concerned
with avenging house tradies so that is
absolutely key in Paul's character and I
like the fact that that's in the trailer
Paul had Paul has the ultimate Choice
here it's like the ref mother also says
in the trailer we've never seen power in
our world like this the power of the
quizat hatak so getting serious in this
one yeah yeah and and and Paul is very
aware in the books especially that this
future that he's fighting for the
survival of House of Trades also carries
the risk of a holy war War a Jihad
killing trillions of people across the
Galaxy so uh it it there is a
selfishness to the path that PA is
trying to is is trying to find it's for
his survival but it also carries these
enormous risks I I really like uh the
shots of water and waves uh in this
trailer as well because you know waves
are this Motif that connects to sand
dunes um and is also connected to
descriptions of time so in the books
Paul's preent vision of the future is
often compared to water in how it's it's
fluctuating it's ever changing it's
evolving shifting currents waves surges
and counter surges like surf against
Rocky Cliffs a boiling of possibilities
so you get this very Dynamic sense of
his Future Vision it's not just some
static certain path it's it's something
that's very dangerous and uncertain and
constantly moving which I think the way
yeah absolutely like he mentions the
yeah the way it's described in the book
it's almost like it makes you feel like
you can you know how it feels to be
preent cuz when he's talking about like
sometimes being able to see a clean path
ahead and then sometimes the vision
maybe being blocked by you know like a
wave and not being able to see like all
the way in the future so that's really
interesting um and also it's um I think
almost every trailer so far has like
hinted really heavily at the
the spice Agony because obviously Paul
becomes really connected with his preent
abilities after he under goes the spice
Agony so I'm curious to see that and I'm
pretty sure not pretty sure but I think
that could be what we see when we see
that that line of uh what looks like
bnie JZ Reverend mothers and cadenas and
Paul walking up to them I think that
might be him going to do the spice Agony
which would be a departure from the book
because in the book he does it I think
either a owner with chny I'm kind of
blinking on it a little bit but yeah
yeah if I remember rightly Paul just
kind of Yol and does the sandworm
drowning and and makes the water of life
and takes it um without telling anyone
uh which is incredibly dangerous and he
ends up being comos for weeks um before
he emerges with his vision unlocked but
yeah as you say it it does look as
though Paul might be coming to the
cadenas for that
purpose
and I really enjoy the costumes and the
appearance the designs of these of these
freman priestesses here because they
they look to me as though these might be
the seadas the priestesses from all
these different Fran tribes across
oracus as though these leaders have all
gathered from across the planet to come
together to you know test Paul or to
meet Paul um and that Central one I
think is Jessica because you know
Jessica becomes one of of the sadena
after the Water of Life ritual I think
that's her costume there there's a great
line in the book um when Paul is in the
coma and again paraphrasing but it's
something like and so began the myth
that Paul muad was both dead and alive
because he goes into this coma and
they're like is he dead he's alive is he
alive and then he finally wakes up so
it's obviously you know um like Jesus
he's like he's like dying and then being
and then waking up and you know being
reincarnated or you know what I mean
it's like wait rising from the dead like
a messiah would yeah on the third day
interesting
part um yeah Frank borrows from so many
different traditions and cultures ABS so
cool um this particular Vision I I think
in other trailers we've seen some
similar shots of what appears to be
Jessica walking around and then Paul
like coming up
coming up a June behind her and it's it
has this sort of nightmarish quality
where it looks like Paul is is trying to
run up and reach his mother but you know
he doesn't quite reach her so you know I
wonder what the what's going on here why
is Paul trying to reach his mother it it
almost feels to me as though you know
Jessica has undergone the spice acony
she has changed into a sadena she's
become a reverend mother and that in
some sense dehumanizes her H it it makes
her something other than than human and
something other than Jessica's mother
than Paul's mother which is something
they explored really well in the first
movie I think cuz in the first movie you
know later was asking Jessica hey like
are you uh my lover and Paul's mother
and someone who's loyal to us or are you
a Bene jeser who was loyal to the Ben
jeser and their plans and I think now
that Jessica under goes this
transformation that that question
becomes even sharper it's like is
Jessica acting in Paul's interests and
in her family's interests or is she some
superhuman Ben a Jer at gigabrain who's
going to manipulate events for for the
sake of their plans I I wonder if in
that sense Jessica is aranged from Paul
and he's trying to reach her again in
this
Vision so can we go like all the way
with spoilers like because I want to
mention something about Jessica's
parentage is that okay yeah let's let's
let's do spoilers spoiler warning
spoiler warning spoiler spoiler spoiler
so so what's interesting about that is
when Jessica's mind would is awakened by
the spice Agony she would have the voice
of the Reverend mother guy Helen M yeah
is her mother in her mind right so when
we talk about like Jessica's loyalty and
whether or not she would be loyal to the
B Jes or not that's a very close
ancestor right there in her mind
speaking to her at all times so um I
feel like that kind of speaks to like
some of the events that maybe happen
later in the series maybe in like
Children of Dune as far as like
Jessica's Allegiance is concerned so
yeah I think that's uh that's that's
pretty
interesting yeah I I I would note that
to the best of my knowledge in the books
written by Frank
Herbert it doesn't say who Jessica's
mother is it doesn't say but I feel like
it's kind of implied because the many
Jes don't really get to know who their
parents are so I would guess if if if if
if if anything would been in Frank
Herbert's notes that his son took and
put in the other books I think it would
have been that would have been one of
the things if I had to guess yeah no I I
agree with that I think that's
reasonable because it is in the prequel
June books written by Frank Herbert's
son Brian Herbert um that is where it
says that gas is Jessica's mother but
yeah I agree it's it's probably
something that Frank planned but just
didn't mention in the in the main
books yeah I just think about the
relationship between gas and Jessica um
we know that um gas directly trained
Jessica we know that she said Jessica
was her greatest student and I really
think there was anep there was an
element to gu that she was she was very
disappointed when she sees what Jessica
has done she's very disappointed in it
her almost like a mother would be
disappointed in her daughter she's like
I had I had hopes in you she almost
seems like a bitter Mom that's like
angry I I agree with that and and isn't
in the first book it doesn't gas we a
little bit when she and she's sort of
weeping for Jessica and the danger that
the atres are going into and so that
there is this sense in their
relationship of that of that tension
again between like are we a family
looking out for our family or are we
these superhuman Benny jerat looking
after the species in this grand plan
that we have I I I mean I I think that
you know they're called reverend mothers
right so a reverend mother is in some
sense a mother to all of Humanity like
they are these abolutely puppeteers but
they are also these caretakers and these
guides and the idea is that the Ben AER
at least they see themselves as this
teacher and as this maternal teaching
figure that tries to guide Humanity
towards Enlightenment and survival and
and self-control and all of these values
and so and so yeah like G gas may be
literally Jessica's mother but I think
gas and the and all the Reverend mothers
are sort of symb Al they see themselves
as the mothers to all
Humanity well that's definitely how they
they see themselves you know they they
definitely think that they're doing
everything they do for the better
betterment of humans and Humanity right
um that's the whole thing behind the
quizat hatak is that the the B Jes have
this vision for how they think humans
should move forward as a species and
they want to use the quizat tatara to be
to like best enact that Vision you know
they want to use his power to make it
happen basically
um so yeah they definitely see
themselves as as the matriarchs of the
human Universe they definitely see you
know most humans as just like silly
humans that they need to kind of keep in
line and you know keep them in check and
manipulate I I like um I don't remember
what book it is but it's the Ben Jes
responding to some other group maybe the
T Lau or the ixian or something and they
basically um send them a note and all
they say is you will be punished it just
reminded me like that's so like Grandma
or like Mom just like you will be
punished it's like that's all they sin
it's like and and they just know they're
going to be punished these witches are
going to mess us up in some way and
they're absolutely going to follow
through on their um threat so yeah the
Benny jzer are the mommies of the Dune
Universe yeah yeah and and it all
connects back to Frank Herbert's
childhood with these Jesuit nuns who
raised him and taught him and it's all
reaching deep into the yian archetypes
in in Frank's brain I think it's it's
wonderful I I I love love how I love how
harsh and rational Dune is but at the
same time it has such an emotional
relatable heart to it deep down which um
I think is really
lovely
absolutely uh well I think it's it's
because Frank Herbert kept the story a
human story right he really wanted to
explore aspects of humanity and I think
that's what makes Dune like really
interesting because we are really
dealing with like human character
characters yeah yeah in the constant
reach for exceptionalism that there is
always those like human foibles that
that you know ground us again and and
Chie embodies part of that Chinese love
bringing Paul back to reality is so
important there's a lot of irelan in
this
trailer oh yeah looking good this shot's
interesting it looks like she's on kitan
the Imperial Kino Planet based on the
trees that are behind
them and uh she appears to be reading a
message yeah I'm not sure what she's
holding in her hand right there it could
be a message of some kind what what I'm
seeing from all the trailers and stuff
and what's been released so far like I
read the transcript of the first 10
minutes of the movie um it seems like
iron is kind of acting almost in an
advisory role to her father like he
takes her more seriously it seems like
than like in the book maybe right so um
yeah so that's that's interesting and
I'm very excited to see Iron's role as
um a scholar right because she seems
very interested in what the truth is
about what actually went down on araus
like she wants to record The Real
History of it all and that makes sense
to me that irong would have that drive
because we see so much of like what she
wrote about the events on arachis and
Paul the trade like throughout you know
Dune yeah very excited to Performance
which is interesting because Dune the
Dune books explore how history and
historians are often wrong um and I
believe there's a point in June book 4
where God Emperor lato executes a bunch
of historians doesn't he doesn't he
horribly execute a bunch of them and
there's
also yeah and there's Al like an
interview with a historian at the
beginning of some editions of book four
I believe where this historian is
telling the truth and he gets killed for
telling the truth and and and so June
has always been interested in you know
how history is recorded and um and what
the nature of Truth
is absolutely
absolutely I like this little message
tube that irelan is looking at there
isn't anything quite like that described
in the books but you know it definitely
connects with that Benny jeser Vibe of
you know secret messages and secret
codes like the Braille on the leaf and
all of these little hidden things um I
wonder if that's you know some kind of
Ben jzer way to send secret messages to
each other maybe you've got to unlock
that tube with some secret pressure
Benny jeser thing um I
think I believe it's Heretics where one
of the mini Jes sisters has like a it's
like a special hood or she has something
in her Hood where she's having a message
projected and she can like read it um I
forget exactly when that takes place I'm
like what is this wild
technology yeah yeah lots of really cool
ways that the VRA communicate that are
interesting because they're very subtle
about their messages and sometimes it's
like messages within messages they have
to have ways of ways of weaving secrets
in in ways that can't be detected by non
bin J it yeah which I guess is all about
the theme of The Power of knowledge
because it all comes back to the power
of the mind being the greatest kind of
power so of course information and
messages are supremely
important um
we yeah gas gas tells irelan that this
is a form of power that our world has
not yet seen the ultimate power so I
suppose she's describing the quizat had
to iron which she should already know
about
right I I was wondering the literally as
you said I was wondering the same thing
so we know that iron was trained by the
B JZ but we also learn I think in dunai
that she's not a very good bnie Jes so I
wonder to like what extent she was kind
of like let in on their inner workings
because she is the emperor's daughter
and I wonder to what extent they would
have trusted her um and when when um I
read Heretics Heretics talks a lot about
about the internal structure of the
Benny JZ and how they kind of operate in
blocks like certain sisters are privy to
certain knowledge yeah true you know
what I mean so um I wonder maybe ilon
wasn't aware of this maybe they didn't
ter tell iron about this part of the
plan maybe she was kept in the dark
about something like this and you know
it's totally
possible yeah yeah I I I agree they um
the Ben J play all sorts of games with
information I mean the funny bit is that
the plan is the Benny Des plan is to put
Iran on the throne and to make her the
Empress of the universe right um at
least prior to the plan of you know the
marriage um to Paul and everything so
it's kind of funny the idea that that
they seem to be continuing the tradition
of having the emperor be mostly a
figurehead who is manipulated by the Ben
jeser without the emperor necessarily
having all that much power
themselves mhm so it's funny that we we
do get a lot more agency from emperor
shadam in this in in the trailers it
seems like we see Iran talking with
shadam and shadam says deal with this
Prophet send assassins
yes send assassins and it's not clear
whether or not the Assassin that he's
planning on sending is fed rtha I don't
know if that's just the way the trailer
is cut or if that's what he's planning
because she we hear iron say fed Raa
he's he's insane or something like that
so um I wonder if if they're including
an element where like the emperor
sending fed rtha to kill Paul the trades
which is very interesting to me yeah
that would be very weird that would be
another big change from the books yeah I
um I I think that yeah I think you're
right that the trailer is cut weirdly
and it might be that um those are two
separate conversations and when they're
talking about fade ralur they might be
talking about how you know fade is going
to uh inherit the rule of how henan and
will rule arus under Vladimir's plan and
the potential I I I mean potentially the
plan is for fed rther to marry irelan
and to rule the universe together right
like theoretic well
no well that's something that fade rther
hopes for in the final chapters of the
book yeah yeah I don't know if the Benny
JZ necessarily want that like the Benny
JZ
um end up basically they just want those
genes they want those quizat hatara
genes so basically they want Paul's
jeans in any way they they can so that's
why do Messiah they're like iron you got
to get pregnant you got to get us this
baby and he's like and she and no Paul
won't do it because he doesn't want to
give the Ben Jes what they want which is
his genes so they can continue
manipulating those Bloodlines and make a
quiza Tara that will serve them yeah and
and Paul's Defiance of that Ben a jzer
plan is is shown quite nicely when Paul
shouts at guas in this trailer and and
uses the voice and says silence and it's
and she looks so shaken yeah I can't
wait I can't wait for that scene uh my
favorite line in that in that scene is
when he says try your tricks on me old
witch uh try looking into that place
where you dare not look you'll find me
there staring out at you that to me is
just so epic and I think he also says
something like
um I remember your gam Jabar you
remember mine I can kill with a word or
something like that and the fan are all
like Shook and they're thinking like oh
the Legends say that that that the Lis
Al could kill with with his voice or
something like that so they're like
shook because he's like still even after
he's one or even after he's like very
very close to Victory Paul is still at
the end playing on the fans's you know
you know on those mythologies still
working to manipulate them by saying
things that they're going to hear and
think oh he truly is the one so it's
interesting it almost becomes second
nature to Paul yeah and and I think
there's a really interesting question
there of like is Paul just acting
confident and angry and bombastic as a
way of cementing his power and his
leadership and his authority over the FR
or is Paul at least partly genuinely
just enjoying the power and enjoying
using power over this old witch who has
tried to control Paul like is this a
sincere emotional reaction this tantrum
almost that Paul is having against
Grandma gas you know like it's angry at
Grandma I think he's a little mad at
Grandma yeah in the live chat he
definitely is in the live chat diso says
he hits grandma with the outside
voice so yeah it is I think very much
this sort of childish emotional thing as
well as this you know political thing so
there's always that tension between you
know
using your using your gigabrain uh
self-control superhuman abilities but at
the same time being sort of uh corrupted
and altered by your human emotions all
at
once also one of the other things that I
really like about this scene in the book
is when Paul just he like kind of starts
exposing the vage desert a little bit
and then guys just like shut up stop
talking she's like stop
talking it is so funny it is so
satisfying you know seeing overconfident
conniving witch gu just be torn apart
and and we talked before about you know
we so hope that AIA turns up as she does
in the book and and because she also has
an enormous amount of fun making fun of
shadam and gas um which is super cool
that might be an even funnier moment
when yeah they're hanging out in the
emperor's like throne room and she's
just like giving him all the Sass in the
world yeah we need more sassy psychic
threeyear olds in Hollywood yeah so we
talked about the Haron a little bit but
like one thing that I have not seen
really in any of the promotional
material or the trailers is thuir howt
yeah do you
think that thuir has to be in this movie
right you don't think they cut him do
you I've been wondering yeah I think I
heard that they um there were some
cutcenes with thuir from the first movie
where thuir is you know C Ed and
interrogated and in the book it's it's
such
a strange and subtle plotline I think in
the book because
Thia thuia thinks that Jessica caused
the downfall of the
atres and thinks that Paul is
dead yeah yeah so he gets captured by
the Haron and they give him in the book
they give him like this poison and only
they have the antidote to it and he said
take the antidote to not be poison by
the you know and um basically the baron
takes him in because he just lost his
Twisted mint hat p so he needs a new
mint hat and over the course of the book
thufir is basically kind of subtly you
know playing the baron and fade rtha
against each other he's doing like very
subtle things to kind of stoke conflict
like he like places that um at Tres
fighter that's not drugged replaces him
with the one that was um was supposed to
be drugged and you know and there's a
lot of things there's a lot of moments
that um where he's trying to subtly
manipulate alar Conan to lead to their D
downfall ah the cat
milk cat milk is great it's not quite we
don't get any cat milk in the book but
you know yeah look I I will quite like I
will forgive David Lynch um making thuir
milk a cat to get the antidote for his
poison yeah I that's such an extra step
it's so bizarre I love it it it would
surprise me if they include all those
details uh from the book in this movie
because it is such an odd confusing
plotline with Thia which like many of
the subplots kind of goes nowhere like I
mean kind of the point kind kind of the
point of thuia as a character I think is
that it it shows how you can be the
smartest person in the world and still
fail because you are misled by your
emotions like thuia has this sort of
rival with Jessica which leads him to
misjudge Jessica um yeah and so you know
Thia has this really lovely death in the
books spoiler where you know thuia dies
in Paul's arms and he you know um ref
does does Thia get ordered to kill Paul
in the end which of course he doesn't do
so you know he gets this lovely death
but it's about the Folly of
overconfidence and the Folly of you know
being smart is not enough ultimately no
so yeah wonder if he'll be what what how
much of a role he'll have I wonder if
they will keep in if they keep him in
and any significant capacity I wonder if
they will keep in the element of him you
know mistrusting Jessica because that
was an element that was totally missing
from the first movie because you know
dcan Idaho also doesn't trust Jessica
and there's a whole scene where he comes
in drunk and basically embarrasses
himself and there's a scene in in one of
my favorite scenes actually between
Jessica and thufir and the first which
would have been in the first movie but
obviously it wasn't which is where she
uses the voice on him yeah and then he's
like what the heck and then she's like
now you know something of the true power
of the V jesire we're not just we're not
just these nun ladies we've got real
real tangible power we can make you do
things that you don't want to do so she
B she's basically telling him if I
wanted to make the Duke some do
something I could do it easily you know
I mean so she's trying to reassure him
but it still doesn't work and he carries
that mistrust
mistrust throughout the entire book um
so we'll see if any element of that is
present I I totally agree like that
scene is such a it's a moment where we
viscerally feel the power of the benzer
when when thuia and the reader goes oh
no like these these Ben Jer are real
like that they are more powerful than we
realize that they can do things that no
one else can do and they are dangerous
um we we don't quite we it's a shame we
don't quite get that in the movie I mean
we see Jessica beat up stillar which was
okay but I'd love to see more of that
visceral sense of power even this shot
from the first un movie I quite like
we've got you know Jessica and thuia
facing each other with the bull head in
between which in a in a symbolic sense
almost evokes that conflict between
thuia and Jessica from the books but
yeah not not quite included in the
movie yeah I would have loved to see it
I was like talking about that scene
before the movie like when the movie
first got announced I was like guys I
really hope this scene is in there
unfortunately it wasn't but um that's
okay cuz like you said hopefully we can
see more you know visceral visceral
elements of the mini jzr powers in this
and maybe the next movie as
well something else I want who knows
what's going on with the show Doom the
prophecy apparently it's called now who
knows what's happening with that yeah
God knows what's going on I haven't got
very high but we'll see what happens
yeah one thing I wanted to note before I
forget is that this particular shot of
the three sandworms smashing the sardak
car in battle uh at the end is very very
similar to this artwork uh by John sh
her which is some like original old
school illustration of um like from back
I don't know exactly when but from
around the time of publication of June
in the' 60s or 70s or thereabouts uh I I
really like how it's so similar to this
classic artwork this particular shot it
looks to me as though absolutely they're
really deliberately drawing from the
imagination at the time because yeah
this is the same shot it's fantastic
yeah to me there have been a lot of like
I feel like direct clear influences
visually from artwork that I've seen
like some of the headdresses that I've
seen like Jessica wearing and stuff like
that looks looks very similar artartwork
work that I've seen a lot of things too
and I'm glad I'm totally glad that
they're pulling from you know what
people that have read the book and drawn
art have um interpreted and taken so I I
really really love the way this whole
sandworm sequence looked and I went
through and looked at all the different
frames and stuff it just looks so good
it is unbelievably satisfying to see the
fritan ride these worms into battle to
really harness desert power in a way
that they never have
before because it's such an epic moment
in in the books it's one of the most
epic moments in the book and we've all
seen the David Lynch version and we know
it really it it doesn't quite work
because I mean like technologically
speaking they didn't really have the
ability to make that work visually the
way we can now and of course also the
Dune miniseries is is very you know it's
not the best either but it's it's this
is going to be amazing to see in
theaters to see on like a large screen
because it's just like truly epic and
this is what they meant by desert power
um cuz the thing is too no one really
knows how many fan there are except for
the fmen the fan are basically keeping
it a secret they're paying people to
like they're they're keeping it they're
doing all they can to keep their numbers
on the low low low so nobody realizes
that there's actually millions of
freemen so when these freemen come in on
the backs of sandworms it's really a
shock to everybody because they had no
idea how much power was actually waiting
in the desert it's just such a great
moment it's such a triumphant moment
yeah and and it's such a slap in the
face to the arrogance and the ignorance
of shadam because this is all about June
is all about how to use the mind and how
to think and the emperor and the
Imperials are an example of how not to
think because they are so arrogant and
so distracted by their luxuries and so
full
of yeah that they that they fail to open
their eyes to certain realities and they
can't even conceive the possibility that
these quote unquote you know dirty
Barbarians in the desert have power and
have knowledge that they can't even
imagine um and so much of it is tied to
the environment and the importance of
the environment and so while you know
while the emperor is hiding in his
spherical spaceship which is another
like really cool shot um in this trailer
the emperor's hiding in his know womb
like egg like spaceship trying to
insulate himself from you know the world
outside um while he's doing that the the
fman are out in the environment learning
to harness the environment and
ultimately they come crashing upon
shadam break open his steel tent smash
it all and and um wipe them away so yeah
I I I think this the sandworms as a
force of nature is captured really well
because they they come out of this storm
like we see the sakar are facing this
like dust storm that sweeps in and
they're like what is this and you know
the sandworms emerge from that fog in a
way that makes it really clear that they
are nature and you ignore nature at your
peril yeah can you imagine the terror of
it yeah yeah yeah like you said it's
very effective that they're coming out
of the storm like that and I'm going to
have to say this okay Game of Thrones
one element of it that I really liked
about the last season a single element I
liked multiple things but one thing that
I liked was when they show the long
night sequence and you have the white
walkers they're coming out of this huge
snow storm right and I really like that
aspect because it's like they're coming
with the winter they're coming with the
snow so I really highlighted them as
being representative of a force of
Nature and I kind of see kind of a
similar image here almost it's like
beware the force of
nature yeah
yeah yeah I agree because that's
something go I was just gonna say um
since we did see the emperor ship enter
entering the atmosphere like at the end
of Dune there's a bunch of ships
hovering above um of Dune above Dune
like great houses of the land just
watching the events happening because
they know that stuff is going down um so
I wonder if we are going to get a guild
Navigator or if that's something that
Vil nil really wants to say for dude
Messiah because obviously the guild
Navigator edric is a huge part of Dune
Messiah so I'm wondering if we're GNA
get like a glimpse of it if he's going
to show it at all because obviously one
of them has to be there I mean
um there's no movement in this universe
without
Navigators yeah I I if I remember
rightly I think vov said in an interview
that we will see a guild Navigator um
which yeah I mean it'll be fascinating
to see what it looks like because there
have been so many different wildly
different interpretations of what a
spacing Guild Navigator looks like and
uh for those who aren't aware these are
the the mutated humans who take a bunch
of spice which gives them the ability to
fly spaceships across Interstellar
distances and so they are this sort of
uh Monopoly that controls all
Interstellar space light in this
universe uh and it's all run through the
the big psychic brain of these fishy
weirdos who live their lives in tanks of
orange spice gas that's what the that's
what The Navigators are so um it'll be
interesting to see what they look like
uh if they appear in the next
movie yeah yeah in the book they're kind
of described as kind of like skinny and
they've got webbed hands and feet and
they're kind of like swimming around in
these tanks full of like this this
spice so yeah it'd be interesting to see
what they look like let's see yeah
and I think part of the point of The
Navigators is again warning us of like
going too deep down the rabbit hole of
like you know the The Navigators have
trained their minds in a super powerful
way which is like great but they've kind
of dehumanized themselves they've made
themselves too reliant on the spice
they've made themselves blind to certain
things there's all this interesting
stuff about how the spacing Guild relies
on the spice on araus but they never
took control of araus because they were
worried that they might mess it up and
lose access to the spice um but
ultimately their their failure to you
know control the spice means that Paul
is able to come along and control them
uh with the spice and so you know Frank
has all these ideas about dependency not
not being overly dependent on a resource
and not you know over specializing
you've got to be flexible and the space
and Guild are too inflexible and too
hyperfocused and too weird and fishy to
ultimately succeed I feel like
throughout the entire series like the um
the balance between the spacing Guild
like that whole balance is like so weird
and shaky and it's almost like he's
waiting for it to crumble waiting for
this Monopoly to crumble and it it gets
kind of close like towards the end of
the of the series so it's interesting to
see how like the Dynamics and the power
balances throughout the Dune Universe
shift over time because nothing stays
the same and that's also one of the
elements that I love about this series
is is nothing stays the same like we see
the progress of you know thousands of
years throughout this series and
everything continues to shift and change
and the balance is always moving right
even things like the role of the Ben
jzer in the human Universe shifts and
and changes um even things like you know
the role that Iraq is plays in the human
Universe shifts and changes you know so
it's it's it's really interesting and I
think that's one of the strengths of
Dune is the that Frank kpet was very
very interested in in what he referred
to as the Long View of History right he
was interested in the development of
humankind over long periods of time the
ways in which we change and the ways in
which we you know stay the
same yeah yeah I absolutely agree I I
love how you know any sense you have of
like good guys and bad guys is always
changing like in this book it feels as
though the freman are the good guys
defeating the Imperials and the hinin
and defying the benzer but then by the
second book The freman and you know
spoilers The freman and the Jihad are
this horrific destructive force uh and
then later in uh books five and six the
Ben jeser who once were sort of the bad
guys and sort of part of the aristocracy
in the later books the Ben jeser are
kind of the Hope for Change and
evolution and growth um and in their
ultimate merging with the honor matr and
all of that they really become the
mother figures in those last two books
they really really like they're taking
care of humanity and in fact they're
like yeah they have worlds and planets
that they're responsible for taking care
of they're like literally like you said
the last hope for the survival of
humanity so really you know mom's
fighting for her baby at that point yeah
yeah um let's talk about fade rala
because there's a lot of cool fade rala
stuff in here so fade rala hakan is the
neph few of the baron Vladimir henan and
Vladimir plans plans to install fade as
the next ruler of araus and fade has
Ambitions of his own as well I um we've
seen a bunch of shots of fade fighting
in the arena and in this shot we got to
see Fades twin blades the White Blade
and the Black
Blade and in the books they talk about
how traditionally the White Blade is
poisoned and the Black Blade is
unpoisoned but one of the little tricks
that fade pulls is that he reverses it
and he puts the poison on the Black
Blade uh instead and so that's one of
the ways that he outsmarts and defeats
someone in the
arena and so I wonder if you know
there's this hilarious bit where fade
licks one of the knives um so I wonder
if I wonder if he's licking the white
knife it's a little hard to tell
but I think he might be well I I don't
know do you think that's I would I don't
know I can't tell but um but we'll
continue I'm sorry I kind of interrupted
you well I'm just wondering if like he's
licking the knife to show that it's not
the poison knife and this is a way of
telling the audience that fade is is
doing this trick and this is his
manipulation maybe he's just doing it to
be weird and it is the poison cuz I know
there are certain poison
or that are only harmful if they come
into contact with your bloodstream right
and you can you know consume
them and not be hurt like like snake
venom I don't know maybe I don't know
yeah no no I wonder I agree like like
maybe that is the poisoned knife and
he's just licking it and like licking it
won't kill you it's only if it
penetrates your skin that it'll kill you
and so that's he's just he's just being
an edge Lord and going oh I'm not scared
of the poison that that might make sense
as well but I love go on I was gonna say
I love the I love the look of the Harin
in this I it's definitely like a a
direct stylistic choice to make them all
bald because in the book They're redhe
heads and David Lynch definitely went
with the red head look with them but um
I I find the VN look very striking and
very there's something about them that's
very off-putting look at this guy
holding the pillow here like right look
this guy he looks like someone like a
Hellraiser character or something I
don't know everyone it's just the whole
look of them is very unnerving and
off-putting and just out there and weird
and I really appreciate the weirdness of
the aronin here they AR gross like the
Lynch ones I appreciate that they aren't
super gross yeah all all of the boils
and the puss and stuff on Vladimir in
the in the 80s was yeah it was a bit
much but yeah I agree like like the
costume and the designs of these haenan
slaves like the weird sort of
BDSM goofy
sensual like gross it's it's like erotic
and it's fat and it's unhealthy and it's
bold and it's just all these very weird
sort of sensory things going on at once
uh that I think is just fantastic it's I
think it's a nice compromise between the
goofiness of of Lynch's take um and a
more sort of menacing realistic sense I
I'll I'll note that to to the very best
of my knowledge the the huckans aren't
redheads in the books at least not in
Frank Herbert's books um I think in the
in the Suns in Herbert's in Brian
Herbert's books some of them are
redheads and in the Lynch movie some of
them are redheads but in the Frank's
books they say that fed rala has dark
hair um and
Vladimir Des yeah you might be right
about that I would have to go like check
again yeah yeah but I mean the redhead
thing is definitely like entered like
that's definitely how a lot of people
think of it so it's definitely You Know
M made a mark but yeah no I so much in
this scene is interesting like it looks
like they're painting fade
black which is
interesting yeah I wonder what is going
on here if it's like some kind of ritual
or if it's some I don't yeah I don't
know what that is I no they did give the
baron a bath in like some kind of black
goo in the last movie after he was when
he was like recovering from the from
lato poison Dr 's poison tooth yeah well
they've got maybe it's just some kind of
war paint they've got such a strong like
black and white um imagery with the
hinin like in those previous trailers we
saw the the pure black and white stark
contrast in the arena scenes I I wonder
if I I wonder if painting fade black is
part of how they in Universe achieve
this black and white effect like maybe
they paint in Black but then they like
reverse the contrast somehow with some
special sci-fi light and that makes him
stark white I don't I don't know there's
like there's some there's some ways they
could be playing with
that yeah it almost
makes it almost makes me feel like you
know the black and white thing shows The
Duality between Paul and fade you know
the yin-yang black and white opposite
thing so I guess that's part of it as
well yeah yeah definitely Paul and and
and fed Roth are obviously juxtaposed
against each other they are definitely
opposites um both um products of the Ben
jeser breeding program and yet they
couldn't be more opposite I think fed
rtha represents the values of the har
conans and then Paul of Trades is meant
to represent the values of of House of
traes so they have to come to this
inevitable Clash because like I don't
know some of you that have read the book
might know that the Benny jeser like
intended you know the Paul was supposed
to be a girl right and so the Benz
intended a marriage between this atra
daughter and the haran son which would
have been fade rtha so they would have
been married but since they're not
coming together in that way it's kind of
they they have to come to this natural
like conflict you know what I mean it's
almost like they're destined to
conflict yeah and at the same time that
there are these differences you know
there's there's certain similarities as
well because they're ultimately both
trying to
sees power um and they're both members
of the aristocracy they both come from
like great houses yeah there's lots of
similarities for sure and and they both
have a capacity to scheme you know like
like fade is fade is not purely like an
an emotional Beast like Glu raban you
know we see him plotting with all of
this Arena slave stuff and uh he's not
quite as good at plotting as Vladimir is
but um yeah I don't know he he he exists
in this sort of shadowy space in between
which yeah I don't know he's really
interesting he's really
cool what other what other bits have we
not
covered well we haven't talked about
Aaliyah yeah we maybe a little bit Yeah
because um definitely um Jessica is
pregnant they mentioned that in the last
book so we know that Aaliyah is going to
be in the movie to some capacity but I
wonder how they're going to do it I feel
like everyone's been pretty tight lipped
on it we haven't seen any indication of
like a child actress playing Aaliyah um
and those of you those of you that have
read the book know that Aliah is not a
normal little girl she
is awakened you know due to you know her
her mom being pregnant when she
underwent the spice Agony so Aaliyah is
awakened with you know the memories of
our ancestors so we have the baby
Aaliyah but
um when people think of St Aaliyah of
the knife we're really thinking of like
the toddler you know the talking toddler
that's really an adult on the inside
right so I'm very very very curious to
see how that's betrayed because that
could potentially be a little weird if
they were like utilizing CGI that could
make it a little bit weird and I just I
just don't know I mean there are good
child actors I think that could pull it
off right they did it in the David Lynch
movie and I think that the little girl
that played AI in that movie was
fantastic I know they dubbed her voice
um which is I mean that's something they
could potentially do in this one too but
I actually have listened to the undubbed
version of Aaliyah from the David Lynch
one and I think the undubbed one is
pretty good too so I think there we
could have a child actor portray this
character and I think it would work fine
so I don't think they necessarily need
to go the CGI route like some people
have been suggesting but I guess it's
it's kind of up in the
air people have definitely been asking
about Aaliyah every time I see a trailer
I I I always read comments of people
saying well where's Aaliyah where's
Aaliyah where's Aaliyah because I guess
she's so
iconic yeah I guess at the same time
that you know we are surprised that they
are they are revealing a lot in these
trailers but there is a lot that uh Deni
is keeping up his sleeve as well
including Aaliyah and Navigators and
Fu's possible involvement that there are
still many many surprises to come out of
here and I feel like they have a lot of
uh flexibility with Aaliyah like there's
going to be a time skip of some amount
of time in the books it's like a couple
of years but in the movie they could
make it longer if they want to age up a
Leo like I I would not be angry if they
had like a 10-year-old instead of a
2-year-old um I think that would be a
reasonable thing if they want an older
actor to play a
Leah yeah well I mean like in when I the
when sci-fi did the adaptations of
children of Doom you know those kids are
supposed to be like 10 years old and um
in the adaptation they're like you know
they're like 18 you know they're like
almost adults basically so I feel like
aging up is is a pretty common practice
in Hollywood and I think that it's
pretty effective most of the time and
most of the time it doesn't matter too
much
yeah yeah uh thanks for the Super Chat
from LMC Doug who says uh who's hoping
to get the troll Master toddler aah
because we do love how how Sassy a leer
is thanks for the Super Chat from BD who
says do you think that the that Frank
was inspired by Arab people living in
the desert for June books I always think
that and um yeah yeah it absolutely is
true that Frank was inspired by a lot of
different uh cultures um from the Arabic
world and North Africa uh to inspire the
FR and he was he was particularly
influenced by a book called The sabes of
paradise which is about uh Muslim
cultures in the Caucasus uh who were
resisting Russian imperial invasions and
that's that's very much what what The
June Story is inspired by but but Frank
Herbert in interviews he also talked
about uh Navajo Indians and Kalahari and
and the S people and a lot of different
peoples from a lot of different places
who um have an interesting relationship
to their environment and and who use
water sparingly and uh Frank Drew from
many
sources yeah many many sources like the
the fan are an amalgamation of a lot of
different cultures to and also if you
think about um what they were called
before they came to Iraq is you know Zen
Sunni Wanderers you know that kind of
implies you know that you know they also
have that influence that's coming from
you know Buddhism right you know um so
there's that as
well yeah yeah it like there's all sorts
of cultures matched together yeah it
mentions the freman ancestors originally
coming from from Sunni Muslims from
Egypt specifically is is mentioned um
but it it also emphasizes that it's been
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years since then and there have been all
these changes and religious schisms and
merges have occurred and so yeah it's
it's it's it's not just a onetoone copy
paste it's not an imitation of any one
culture it's an imagining of of a new
culture with roots from many different
real cultures and and it's important to
note that you know the freman the freman
are most closely inspired by some Arabic
and Islamic cultures but really the
whole Dune Universe has this Bud Islamic
philosophy that is inspired by Islamic
and Buddhist ideas the Ben jeser um
quote and refer to a lot of those ideas
and and the at trates and um even the
Imperials in some in some bits it's it's
not just the freman who are Islamic it's
kind of a Buddhist Islamic Zen universe
that has imagined because that is the
philosophy that he's interested in yeah
and that's also like the aesthetic I
think that he he was interested in
um yeah um was I going to say uh the
fan I'm blanking on what I was gonna say
sorry keep talking talking I'll take it
in a second thanks for the Super Chat
from deeb who says what do you guys
think fed ralur puts in his wheat bicks
I think that fed rur puts
uh the blood of innocence and black bath
goo into his wheat pcks makes
sense Max says did you did you guys see
the shot of the freman on a
shoreline looks like that bit in June
Messiah um you're talking about Paul
when he was like standing in front of
the water I think that was probably like
a vision or a memory so I don't think
we're going to see like on off on
kaladan again because I think that was
kaladan probably like a vision or a
memory of
kaladan yeah
I or possibly maybe a vision of the
future imagining water on oracus which
is the you know terraforming dream of
the fman um but yeah it's it's not
entirely clear who this is if it's Paul
or Jessica or someone else I think it's
possible that Max might also be
referring to these shots um around the
Jihad Visions in 2021 where it it
appears as though this crowd of freman
are on kaladan because it's this it's
this watery world with all these Legions
of freman standing around and I thought
that was a really interesting choice and
a change from the books because it it
suggests that this holy war that might
happen uh threatens Paul's home World
specifically like it's not just
something that will kill billions of
people it's something that will affect
Paul's home world and I think that
that's a good way of subtly giving more
personal Stakes to the danger of the
holy
war yeah absolutely and I remember what
I was going to say um and in about like
the religion of the fan right yeah and
how we were talking about how they are
kind of like this amation of a bunch of
different like cultures and religion um
that goes back to what I was saying
about Frank Herbert being really
interested in the development of
humanity over long periods of time yeah
because something interesting that
happens with religion over time is the
fact that it changes and evolves with
humans and with the culture that it's a
part of right religions over time you
know split and become new and unique
religions they they merge together I
mean so I think Frank Herbert was also
playing with that idea you know when
developing you know the firman culture
and fman religion he's playing with the
idea of like how cultures you know merge
together and like like break off and
split and and things like that so yeah
that's that's the thing I was going to
say yeah there's some really fun World
building where it mentions oh yeah and
then 3,000 years ago the third Muhammad
came along and you know he was sort of a
heretic who made this new split of the
religion and it it mentions uh quote the
the the malth sari Mahayana Christianity
Zen Sunni Catholicism and Budd Islamic
traditions in the orange Catholic Bible
so Frank had an
enormous yeah he he had so much fun just
smooshing all these cultures together
and imagining this new
philosophical um perspective for this
for this future
Universe it's very interesting and I
love um like when when you get certain
quotes from things like the orange
Catholic Bible because they sound
familiar if you're like familiar with
certain religious texts but they're like
not actually familiar like Thou shalt
not make a the machine in the likeness
of of the human mind you know it sounds
like one of the Ten Commandments right
like the way it's written sounds so
familiar but it's like not white yeah I
think that's really interesting yeah I
think part of why Dune succeeds in
creating this feeling of like very real
religious ideological weight and
authenticity I think that how Frank
achieves that is that he steals from
real religions and real um ideological
you know real phrases real quotes that
he takes he plucks out of all these
different languages and histories and
inserts them into his story and so you
know like like a magpie he has
accumulated these these real um
historical words with weight and used
them for his fiction and it really works
for Dune because Dune is really supposed
to be like kind of read as like you know
like this potential future history of
humanity right so it's like of course
they would have bits and pieces of our
old cultures and old religions like
mattered out about because like really
we we all started on this little egg of
Earth and then little bits of Earth went
out into the universe and Seed
themselves on all these different
planets and split up and remerged and
you know so of course there's little
bits and pieces of everything smattered
all about it just makes too much
sense thanks for the Super Chat from the
lady Eternal who says say what you will
about the Sci-Fi adaptations but Barbara
kova was amazing as charie powerful and
equal to Paul without having to change
her character loves Enda but Barbara
knocked it out of the park are you a fan
of the uh 200000 sci-fi
adaptation I like uh certain aspects of
it I'm a I'm more of a I'm a bigger fan
definitely of the Children of Dune one
with James McAvoy as opposed to the
Frank Herbert's Dune adaptation I think
it's okay I think it's good I think it's
more accurate than the David Lynch Dune
um but I there's certain problems with
it I think like visually it kind of
fails a little bit like the costumes
don't work necessarily that great I
don't really like agree with the casting
from Paul really um so there's elements
of it that I don't like as as much and I
don't think fade rothes really that
great and I think he's kind of
forgettable but I do I do agree that the
casting for chny is is one of the better
casting choices although I do think that
both chny and Paul kind of looked too
old for the roles that they were
portraying so that's one thing that I do
like about the new version you see these
these costumes are just like a bit are
kind of out like Iron's headpiece this
Wing thing that the emperor has going
on it's just it's just not okay yeah
that they had a very limited budget and
they spent all of it on hats and
costumes thanks for the Super Chat from
Ian he says great collab these trailers
feel four times longer than their
runtime how's that sandworm attack
reveal and Josh says do you think the
story will have the same impact if the
movie focuses more on action like vov
has
hinted they sure are adding a lot of
fight scenes and explosions aren't
they yeah that's that's an interesting
thing because I feel like I I don't know
if I've ever had an experience where
I've read a book and then watched an
adaptation where the adaptation has had
the exact same impact there's always
there's always a change and impact
there's always a change in the way it
feels because it it's an adaptation and
it has to be different like when you're
reading something in your mind and
you're imagining everything in your own
head it's it's just going to be
different from the adaptation so I have
no doubt that the impact is going to be
different but like what I'm hoping for
is that it you know it stays in line
with the themes and ideas that are
present in the book you know like as as
as best as it can you know the core
ideas and themes need to remain intact
you can change a lot as long as the core
ideas and themes are intact yeah I I I
think the challenge is that like it's
okay to add all these fight scenes and
explosions as long as you can connect
those fights to the thematic and
character and emotional conflicts that
are going on like one of the things that
I like about the incident where you know
Paul and the freman attack gurnie and
the
Smugglers and then realize that it's
gurnie and they reunite I think part of
the point of that is that we see From
gurn's perspective that he's shocked by
how Paul has changed and Paul and the
freman have become more ruthless and
capable and powerful and so we we get
this outside perspective on Paul where
we get sort of shocked by you know look
at who Paul has become and that connects
to I think some of the dialogue in this
trailer when Chie says you know you will
never lose me as long as you stay who
you are but of course inevitably because
of the power because of the spice
because of the precence Paul inevitably
changes enormously and that will test
his relationship with Chie so as long as
they connect those fight scenes and
explosions with the emotional and
thematic art of the story I I think
it'll be okay it it remains to be seen
how much they will succeed at doing that
well I do know you know from watching
like Blade Runner
2049 that Vil n is is is just incredible
at action scenes he like I feel like
he's one of the best I feel like if I'm
going to watch an action scene vov is
the guy to do it because like Blade
Runner 2049 had some of the most
gripping action moments that I've ever
seen in any movie so I'm I'm pretty
confident that vov knows what he's doing
and he's not just throwing it in just to
throw it in you know what I mean yeah
look I I have no doubt that we're going
to have a good time regard you know even
if they miss uh some of the subtler
aspects we're going to have a good time
I I mean I think that some of the fight
choreography stuff in the 2021 June
movie was not great like you know gurnie
is meant to be the greatest fighter in
the universe but he only briefly kills a
couple of henin I mean his SE his scene
with Paul was good I enjoyed that um
Duncan's fight choreography I feel like
was a little bit hid and miss so I don't
know like we'll see we'll see how it
goes but but but I mean certainly in
this trailer there's a lot of very
spectacular action shots going
on yeah
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Sushi
Kebab guy who says why doesn't the bald
boy put poison on both blades also where
was he when oracus was getting raided
love the content makes it more
fun makes it more fun yeah he was proba
he's probably on Gat Prime I'm pretty
sure when araus was being
raided
Yeah question yeah I I mean it it's not
like he's a super well I mean he is a
good fighter but he's very young um is
it his he's no Fen ring yeah he's no
he's no Fen ring fed is is he 16 or yeah
he's he's 17 years old um at this point
so and and in the uh battle for oracus
against the atres he would have been
yeah about 16 years old so he's not
necessarily who you're going to like put
on the front lines of the battle for
arus like Vladimir is grooming Fade to
be the the next political ruler and the
leader of house AR Conan like he's not
necessarily who you would put in the
middle of the battle but W with the
knives and and stuff he's preparing here
for a ritual gladiatorial combat this is
not a fight for his life or it's not
meant to be a real hot blooded fight for
his life what what the hakin normally do
is they they drug these slave combatants
to the point where where the slaves
can't even really properly fight back so
the hinin brag about oh fade has killed
100 slave gladiators but it's not a real
dangerous fight because they're all
drugged and you know fade is so highly
trained so so it's kind of a fuss um and
the whole you know the blades are part
of that it's a ceremony um and so you
know they don't give him every possible
weapon to
win yeah and there's a part in the book
where kind of thar because he's trying
to under undermine the Haron
he kind of sets it up so that the slave
isn't actually drugged so um he actually
almost like gets the better of fade
rotha so like fade is actually isn't as
good as like people think he is he
actually almost gets the better of him
but he ends up still dying but um yeah
but that's an interesting part yeah fa
Fade's not like the most dangerous guy
in the world um he does yeah almost get
killed by that atradius guy and it's
interesting that in this movie uh
they're using lville who is this movie
only character who was with the atres in
the first movie and they're now bringing
back as a hinan captive to fight against
fade in the arena which I think is a
nice little connection which you know
probably won't be noticed by many but
but this guy was in the previous movie
as well which is kind of
neat um Raa awesome name too I always
thought the name Fed rtha was really
nice to say like I all the name Nam and
and terms in Dune I feel like really
roll off the tongue and I think that's a
skill as a writer as well quizat sedak
fade ratha you know bny jzer they all
sound really nice on the lips yeah yeah
there's a sort of like sensual quality
to feed Ral hawen and which I think
connects to their to their meaning as a
family um although you know I've seen
tweets making fun of June cuz it's like
you know it people names in this story
it's always either you know quizat hak
you know gas mahim or it's like John or
Paul or Duncan you
know extremely normal names for some of
the characters yeah yeah you might get a
weird name like miles T well miles T
isn't that bad it's miles T is a bit of
a weird last name I've never really
heard that one but I love how the later
um the later books have a character
called
odr and ADR is meant to be this
Corruption of the name atres over
thousands and thousands of years it's
the language has been twisted and
altered and evolved into something
else yeah that's that's really cool cuz
like in the later books we're still
dealing with you know atres ancestors
like the main characters are still atres
ancestors you know you got like Lucilla
and you know darwi um and Miles T um
yeah so it's we're still dealing with
the the atres like thousands of years in
the future yeah these certain Bloodlines
do remain relevant I I love this shot of
the spherical Imperial spaceship
descending to
oracus uh it looks like a meteor it
looks like some destructive artificial
outside interloper about to crash onto
this planet I love how artificial
it I love the look of it because I love
the I love how it's entering the atmos
and it looked like it's coming with such
force and speed and it just looks like a
like a bullet like about to pierce the
surface of AA it's like the emperor is
coming and bringing all of his Rage with
him yeah it's a really nice looking uh
symbol and I'm just I wish there was
there was a longer shot of it in the
trailer right yeah yeah great also looks
like a Pokeball I saw someone say that
it looks like a little bit does that
mean that EMP shadam is a Pokemon
Christopher Wan is a Pokemon
perhaps in the background I like that
there's a moon or something one of the
moons yeah which sort of mirrors super
cool the spherical spaceship as though
the spaceship itself is also some kind
of planetary body something something
otherworldly yeah I can't wait to get a
a sense of the the scale of this ship
cuz like in in in it coming into the
atmosphere right now you can't really
see the scale of it so I can't wait to
see what it's like bes a building cuz I
get the sense that this thing is
enormous this is a palace that's flying
in the sky right so I can't wait to see
what the scale of it is like when it
lands on the
surface yeah I I think we saw it in the
first movie when it lands on
arus so the one that lands on um kaladan
when when the comes yeah I I didn't know
if it was the same I didn't know if it
was the same same one or not because I
didn't know if the emperor was actually
on that one or if that was just the ship
that sent like members of The L rad and
the the invoy sending the message so I
thought maybe the emperor would have
like his own vessel that's a palace that
like when he wants to travel but it
could be the same one it could be the
same one well entirely certain I think
you're right it might be a different one
because this spherical one in the
trailers is super
reflective so I don't know if it it just
gets turned onto mirror mode or
something or if that's like a different
ship that's um a different ship to the
non-reflective
one
yeah feel huge no matter what like if
they yeah it's just a huge I remember
seeing this scene where this thing lands
in theaters and just being just blown
away by it it's like the scale of it and
the size of it yeah yeah I I I think
it's great I mean the the sort of like
spherical like egg sort of symbolism
connects with the Benny jeser as well
cuz I think they have like this egg like
ship that's quite nice it's an
interesting desert ship is very egg
likee it's very very it's like
definitely egg
shaped um so we got one of our first
proper like shadam Christopher Walkin
lines when he tells his daughter irelan
deal with this Prophet send
assassins and I love how sort of uh
casually he says like oh you know send
assassins duh that that's what we do
with problems we have the m
it tells you a lot whoam is that he just
s of casually says yeah violence
obviously that's what we're going to do
and you guys should notice that he says
deal with this Prophet not deal with PA
trates because he's not aware of the
fact that Paul trates survived no one is
so just keep that in mind no one really
knows that Paul is alive they know that
someone is out here mobilizing the fan
they don't think it's the son of the
Duke traes they're pretty convinced that
Paul and Jessica died in the desert so
that's really interesting cuz no one
ever thought that the fman would take
them in yeah which it's so interesting
that they're adding this plotline with
irelan investigating you know in
previous trailers she was saying What if
Paul trates is still alive which is like
okay if irelan does discover the truth
that Paula trades is alive and that he
is now a leader of the freman is Iran
going to tell shadam Hey Dad I found out
that you know you know that Duke you to
murder yeah his son is in charge of of
this Rebellion on this planet now um I I
don't think Iran can tell shadam that
because part of the point of the ending
is that shadam is shocked to find that
the atres are alive and the fman are
attacking and so will
irelan discover the truth or not and if
she does discover the truth why doesn't
she tell shadam is it possible that
Iran's loyalties might be swayed towards
Paul
I don't know maybe she tells maybe she
tells him and he kind of just like
dismisses it or maybe um you know it it
could be okay maybe iron doesn't even
know right that the emperor is the one
that set up the destruction of House of
tradies right and maybe he's kind of
dancing it around it because he doesn't
want her to know because like like we
all know he had to do it he had to do it
undercover because he can't have the
other houses of the lad being fully
aware of the fact that he helped take
out House of traes because no one would
feel safe and it would cause chaos so
it's very possible that iron doesn't
know that her father is involved or
doesn't maybe she she might very well
suspect it see in my mind I'm Prett I'm
thinking that somehow iron gets it in
her head that the har conans and her
father were involved with the
destruction of House of traes you know I
mean like she realizes it and
um yeah I I could it's going to be an
interesting Dynamic I think she's going
to figure it out and I feel like he'll
either reject the news or um I don't
know I I feel like he might just not
believe her or not want to believe it I
think that's might be what we're going
for here I I think you're right that
irelan doesn't know that her father the
emperor caused the downfall of the atres
CU in the first uh trailer for this
movie irelan says in the shadows of
oracus lie many Secrets but the darkest
of them all may Remain the end of House
of traes so it seems like she doesn't
know and she wants to find the truth and
so I guess eran's going to have this
moment where she's like oh my God my
father uh did this horrible thing trying
to defeat the atres and the question is
like will irelan be surprised by that
because in the books irelan knows that
her father the emperor is horrible in
the books irelan knows that her father
has probably tried to assassinate her
several times it's mentioned in the
books so maybe they're going for
something different in the movie where
irelan doesn't realize how awful her
father is
yet and and she discovers over the
course of this movie that that her
father is more of a monster than she had
realized yeah I definitely see a process
of her discovering over time that her
father is actually the one that was
behind it all yeah I definitely I
definitely think that's where we're
going because we need to give iron
something to do in this movie I think so
that's definitely going to be one of the
subplots is her um figuring stuff out
figuring out her father's involvement
mhm it's just so interesting the thing
is to go on well I was just going to say
that iron is loyal to Paul a traes for
the most part I mean definitely her
loyalty is like kind of like wavering in
Dune Messiah but by the time we get to
Children of Dune she is loyal to House
of Trades and loyal to Paul's children
so I I don't think yeah okay yeah she
she goes back and forth doesn't she and
and I guess it makes sense that if vov
is hoping to make a movie of the next
book June Messiah it does make sense
that he's he's starting to give Iran
more agency and exploring Iran's
loyalties more but it'll be interesting
to see how that affects the ending
because in the ending of the of the
first book irelan is still very much a
porn she doesn't have a lot of agency
when she just gets handed to Paul and
told to marry him so I wonder if you
know in the movie are they going to have
irelan choose to marry Paul and choose
to Ally with Paul partly because she's
discovered that her father the emperor
shadam is uh more of a monster and a
killer than she than she realized I
guess that's one possible angle they
could be going
for you might be right about that I
think that might be what we see as
opposed to it just being like okay now
marry him and you don't get a choice I
think we might see her yeah yeah because
her from her point of view I mean Paul
traes it'd be a great marriage for her
you know I mean if she actually could
you know produce an air she'd be you
know Queen of the Universe I mean it's
not like it's it's a bad marriage for
her you know what I mean it's a great
political move
honestly yeah but and and the extent to
which she's acting on her own personal
desires and Ambitions versus acting for
the Benny jates plan is another aspect
of it CU like her relationship with gas
is going to be interesting cuz they also
have this interesting relationship in
the books where gas doesn't respect
irelan very much no um but they have
this sort of mental Mente relationship
nonetheless and she uses her where she
can like any place where she can utilize
iron she makes use of it yeah and iron
kind of just seems like this kind of
fumbling character that's kind of like
this almost like this anxious Benny
jesire that doesn't have very good
emotional control and it's another um
yeah I I forget I I think it's dun M
it's Dune Messiah where they're all
sitting at the table and iron is visibly
getting very very frustrated at the
conversation that's happening and it's
like yeah it's it's interesting because
I um definitely in D Messiah you see
Frank Herbert play with the idea of like
irong like grasping for more agency and
control and being denied it and denied
it and being very frustrated because of
that so yeah yeah you kind of feel sorry
for her because because like you
definitely feel sorry for her I I think
compared to Paul and gas and Jessica who
were literally these superhuman psychic
Giga brains irelan seems like fumbling
and foolish compared to them but I think
that Iran Iran still is a very smart
capable person she's just not as capable
as these these superhuman people um
which sort of yeah she's in a really
unfortunate position and and that's you
know part of why she spoiler plots
against Paul in book two is is because
she's been put in this really just
uncomfortable political emotional
situation it sucks for iron yeah it
really really really ends up like
sucking
yeah the the thing it just keeps coming
back to I think for me is like just to
to what extent are they going to capture
the message of Paul's rise being kind of
terrible like there's this text that
shows up in this trailer that says
Destiny
arrives and so you know I I I hope that
they are they're leaning on this you
know classic fantasy Hero Journey stuff
so that they can undermine it and
subvert it later is is I hope what
they're doing CU I'm sure there's Studio
Executives behind V saying oh we don't
want Paul to be a bad guy we don't want
to talk about the the Jihad and The Holy
War let's make this an an optimistic
uplifting story let's have it rain at
the end like in the David Lynch movie oh
I really hope they stick the landing and
and get the more cynical message in yeah
I wonder if sometime towards the end of
the movie will like because like I I get
the sense that throughout it Paul will
be having these fragmented visions of
the future and he's not really sure
what's going to happen I wonder if if
sometime by the end of the movie
we'll see Paul have a vision that's more
clear of the future and maybe we'll see
the Jihad marching out into the universe
and the and the atres flag and the
shrine of his father's skull and we
might see like a like almost like a
Quick Clip show of like some of the
things that are going to happen in the
future like okay yeah now it's going to
get really bad from this point on like
just just like this ominous Vision that
hints at the things to come so it kind
of solidifies okay now you've gained
this Victory but the things that are yet
to come will be far more terrible than
anything that would have happened other
otherwise that could be an interesting
thing and that kind of like Hypes up the
next movie in a way I don't know if
they' do something like that or not yeah
yeah something to make it more like
explicit um visually would make a lot of
sense I agree I I think it's interesting
also these um we get these shots of fade
standing in some kind of big arena place
um in front of a crowd that's like
cheering for him and that's something
that we don't get to see something like
this in the book not like separate from
the arena anyway I I love the
architecture here you know it looks like
ribs or it looks like the sort of ribbed
shape on the inside of an animal's mouth
or something like they've been swallowed
by a
whale
yeah so so I really like the visuals of
this scene and I wonder what the um what
the point for the story will be in this
scene is is this like presenting Fade to
the people saying fade is off ially the
the air to to G Prime and I wonder if
that's what they're doing I think you I
think you're um intuition is spot on
with that I think fade is being
announced as like the naar and it's like
yeah this is the future leader of house
har Conan behold the future leader I
think that's exactly what's going on
here yeah and it's a wonderful
comparison to uh the shots of Paul in
sich to beer when when he steps up as a
leader and he is presented to the crowd
having these sort of parallel um scenes
seeing the differences and the contrasts
between them is going to be really
cool yeah I definitely agree I like I
like this uh leather thing that fade has
in this image
here yeah well F Fade's outfit is cool I
feel like his his sort of necklace thing
looks like it looks like a chain cuz the
hinin are all about slavery and stuff
um lots of really great subtle costumery
going
on um yeah hyper in the live chat asks
about sting um we were talking about the
uh year 2000 miniseries before not the
uh 1984 Lynch movie because the Lynch
movie is the one where fade is played by
Sting and there he is uh very memorable
in that role for sure very memorable
I reckon we might wrap up this live
stream shortly uh if people have
questions that they're burning to uh ask
or topics you'd like us to discuss Chuck
it in the chat Chuck it in the super
chats and we'll uh have a look um in the
meantime Quinn I heard that you are
releasing a comic
book yes uh the 30-day campaign just
finished running but you can still get
the book in demand it's called the LI
behind the star it's a science fiction
graphic novel it's my second graphic
novel uh you can check out the link in
the description if you're interested
check out like the trailers and the
images that we have listed it's
basically this uh semi dude inspired
inspired by a lot of Science Fiction
things that I read um it's got elements
of cosmic horror and
Adventure um and yeah it's been really
exciting to produce it and it's been
kind of a process that's taken about a
year and a half to finally get it to
this point where we can start doing the
pre-sales and it's been really good so
far we were like over 500% funded so
it's definitely happening and it's it's
very very exciting so anybody can check
it out if you're interested Link in the
description thanks guys oh congrats on
the uh crowdfunding success thanks man
what is some of your um what are some of
your influences cuz I know your previous
graphic novel tajer had a lot of sort of
witchy Benny jeser energy to it what
what are some of the ideas and
influences in this new
one well uh a big major influence is the
work of Octavia Butler who did a lot of
you know afro futurism uh last year I
read her series xenogenesis which is
about like the end of the human race and
these aliens that intervene to save the
human race but they offer us salvation
through change um they basically want to
merge with humans um so essentially
humans will stop existing and become
something else this hybrid of them and
and humans so this is the way this
particular race breeds and there's just
something about the way Octavia Butler
has these very specific ideas about
humanity and the way we engage with each
other and she confronts you with those
ideas in a very like almost
uncomfortable way in her work in a very
visceral way that makes you really
really have to like think about what
you're like reading and seeing and I was
just very inspired by that so I wanted
to create uh a story that you know was
kind of maybe a little bit uncomfortable
in a similar way that took um things
like my knowledge about the world and
you know how I grew up and and
Incorporated them into this story um
right so I have the element of like
these um these mushrooms that people
that this specific civilization of
people consumed over time and through
the consumption of these mushrooms
certain members of the society gain the
ability to hear this signal that was
coming from outer space that these
mushrooms are also responding to and
connecting to and over time and over
time they kind of develop this Advanced
civilization after being changed by
these mushrooms and over um they develop
biological technology the ability to
produce all sorts of chemicals and
biological Technologies weapons all
forms of technology um and ultimately
they create a biological spaceship and
send nine young people who have the
ability to strongly hear this signal the
kamora they call it and they of course
attach like various you know religious
uh connotations to this idea of the
kamora so they're going into outer space
to find it this potential goddess to
figure out what it is that has been
sending the signal and changing them um
so that is what it's about and like I
said it's got elements of cosmic horror
and adventure and I'm really excited
about it really really excited about
it awesome yeah now one of the things I
love about your channel is that you
cover so many different stories you
you've read so widely and and delved
into so many different uh classic and
and more obscure Sci-Fi series so um I'd
love to see how all those different all
that sci-fi knowledge goes into this
this original story that's um that's
really cool so there's a link in the
description for everyone to go and uh
check it
out thanks guys awesome um all right I
think we will wrap this up shortly uh
thank you so much everybody for
listening thank you mods thank you
Schubert reads for moderating the live
chat uh this live stream will be
available as a podcast as well you can
listen on a podcast app or on Spotify or
wherever uh please like this live stream
please subscribe to alt shift X And
subscribe to Quinn's
ideas shout out to my friend Mike
Blacklist Universe in the comments there
he does the all the covers for George R
Martin's comic book books theong of Ice
and Fire Comics cool uh and oh and
you've got a podcast as well right Quinn
I do it's called Cosmic Chronicles
podcast and we do bi bi-weekly episodes
and um we cover various science fiction
topics and talk about their relation to
the real world we usually start with a
base of you know like a set of books or
movie and we just basically talk about
ideas that are related so yeah we've
been doing that for a few months now and
it's been going pretty swimming main L
sweet uh and as for alt shift X at the
moment we are working on finishing a big
video about Jon Snow called the real Jon
Snow I think that will be done in
January I think uh and it'll be very
exciting to get that out because it's
the biggest Al shift x video ever we
will do more Song of Ice and Fire videos
we will do more Dune videos especially
when uh the
second June movie comes out on March 1st
we'll do more House of the dragon videos
weekly live streams and videos when
House of the Dragon season 2 comes on
and uh and yeah there's lots of cool
stuff happening are you going to cover
the three body problem
Quinn the the Netflix show yeah most
certainly absolutely I've done like as
you probably know like a few videos on
it so far so yeah I'm definitely going
to talk about the show when it comes out
it seems like they're changing a lot but
I'm definitely interested in seeing what
they do with it with the material
interesting D and D strikes
again
yeah we'll see we'll see cool all right
well lots of cool stuff coming up on
Quinn's Channel and on alt shift X and
uh I'm excited for all of
it yeah me too thanks for listening guys
yeah thanks so much for coming on Quinn
it's a pleasure
absolutely anytime man anytime fantastic
all right well thank you everybody and
uh we'll see you next
time
cheers bye
guys